So I'm going to describe that process, and I'm going to write it out
in a, fairly precise way, but not as actual python code. Because it
will end up being your job to finish the python code to
do this. But I want to describe it precisely enough so we can
ask some questions about it. So we're going to start with some seed
page and to crawl will just be that page. The list containing just
the seed page, and crawled will be empty. And we're going to keep going
as long as there are more pages to crawl. And for each step
we're going to pick one of the pages, we'll add that
page to crawled to keep track of the fact that we've
crawled it. Then we'll find all the link targets on
this page, and add those to tocrawl, and we'll keep going
as long as there are more pages in tocrawl. And
then when we're done we'll return crawled. So that's the basic
process that I've walked through. So for this quiz. I
want to see that you understand the process that we're using
to crawl the web, well enough to understand what will happen
if we do this starting from the seed page on the
example test site. And you can try exploring that site yourself.
So the choices are, it will return a list of all
the URL's that can be reached starting from the seed page.
The second choice it will return a list of some of
the URL's but not all of them that are reachable from
the seed page. And the third choice, it will never return.